[Music]
we instinctively use the lessons of
European history to explain Asia's
future and we almost it is incredibly
difficult to make the argument we should
look at Asia's history if we want to
understand where Asia is going to go in
the future
the most common way that we think about
power transitions in international
relations is to look at a war between
Sparta and Athens from 2,500 years ago
the Peloponnesian War in ancient Greece
there a rising power caused fear and a
declining power and they ended up
inevitably fighting lucidity --zz wrote
about this in his famous history of the
Peloponnesian War and almost ever since
then what ir scholars and international
relations scholars and historians have
done is used the example of the
Peloponnesian War as the most
foundational way in which we think about
rising powers rising powers are
inevitably ambitious declining powers
are inevitably fearful and they always
clash at some point well when we get to
modern China today the example seems to
fit perfectly which is China's rising
power it's very ambitious America is a
declining power
it's very fearful and so at some point
there's almost an inevitable chance that
the two are gonna come into conflict and
in fact you hear this over and over
again you know and yet in a way isn't it
weird to think about a primitive
infantry battle between two Greek
villages from 2,500 years ago that would
have any implications for what
contemporary modern China is how they're
gonna behave today I mean in a way it
seems like a quite quite a stretch and
in many cases I think that simply taking
the lessons of history in this way bias
us towards looking towards conflict in
ways I don't think actually are
necessarily going to play out
particularly in contemporary East Asia
that is what we do is we always take
European history as the sum of all
things and somehow what happened again
2,500 years ago in ancient Greece is
going to predict what's going to happen
in modern
and I don't think that's the case at all
especially when we look at how East
Asian history worked if we were to take
East Asia on its own terms
instead of using Europe to explain Asia
why don't we look at East Asia and if we
took it on its own terms
one thing that we would find is that
first of all China's not really rising
China has always been big sometimes it
goes into a period of decline and then
it comes back and this is more return
than a rise so it's not anything new to
the countries in the region in many ways
what happens is China's dominance
China's massive size has been effective
life in East Asia for for literally
centuries so this is nothing new so it's
not at all clear to me that we should
view this as a rising power any more
than we would views the United States as
potentially a rising power the other
problem is if we use East Asian history
one of the biggest lessons we would
learn from East Asian history is that
the dangers that arise to countries in
the region are almost always internal
not external so even for rising and
declining powers the fears or the
threats there is a much domestic as they
are internal so almost every single one
of China's dynasties over the centuries
the Tong the Ming almost all of them
fell because of internal rebellion if
I'm a Chinese leader today I'm as
worried as as much about internal issues
as the external issues and in fact one
thing we know is that China spends more
on internal security than it does on
external defense so even now it's not
clear that China's ambitions are all
directed outwards they're probably just
as concerned about internal and if we
look at the United States the lessons if
we were to take the lessons from East
Asian history and say wow instead of the
inevitable war that Thucydides wrote
about what if we were worried about the
lessons from East Asian history which is
the Japanese dying to know the Japanese
Shogun's all fell from internal
rebellion
in Vietnamese dynasties almost all fell
from internal rebellion as well so what
would the lesson for today be
self-inflicted wounds in both the United
States and China may matter more than
any titanic struggle between them in
fact if I was a look at the United
States today the challenges that we face
are far more internal than they are from
China yes
China and the United States haven't
worked out a totally stable equilibrium
we have things at the margins we have to
deal with maybe some uninhabited rocks
in the South China Seas maybe some trade
disputes but those are not things that
are gonna lead to Titanic struggle for
global dominance and I don't see any bet
war between China and the United States
along those lines but I do see huge
issues in China itself from internal
security to environmental issues to a
rapidly aging population and frankly I
see just as many issues in the United
States as well if we look at the threats
that are facing United States it's a
deeply divided country it's a massively
under invested infrastructure in whether
it's our transportation or education and
in many ways we have the the issues we
face today are much more internal than
external so I was to say what do I think
about the the future of US China I'd say
it's much more about sort of scoring an
own goal than it is about any kind of
massive battle between the two countries
Europe isn't the measure of all things
and if there's different examples or
different experiences in East Asia and
if they have different implications for
the present of the future then we ought
to take it seriously and in many ways
that's what I think that uh people like
myself that's our task right our task is
to try and show understand East Asian
history without making a cartoon out of
it without making a caricature out of it
but taking it seriously
and if some things are the same then
fine and if some things are different
than we need to point them out you know
and this goes back to really an
important theoretical point or a point
about how we think about the world which
is that in many
cases local knowledge about situations
this is important as any kind of broad
theory about the way of the world
inevitably works and we want to know
both we want have some good theories but
we also really want to make sure that
those theories apply to the region and
only with having that kind of knowledge
can you really take East Asia on its own
on its own terms
[Music]